how are you doing Robert all right how
are you hi I'm well thank you well
listen Robert loved you in this film
you're a pretty funny guy pretty funny
guy I think you know
I gotta say you know as someone with
Italian American Roots is there any you
know is there anything that like kind of
resonated with you and your own family
experiences
well my uh yeah I mean if there was
stuff of course that made me
um
getting the script Paul White sent me
the script he directed me in in Meet The
Little Fockers and in a movie called
being Flynn and he Paul had sent me was
producing this he sent me the uh the
script and
um I I read it and liked it and I just
then wanted to have it what I do
sometimes is many times before I do a
movie I if I'm really interested I have
a table read and we sit around read the
script lift it off the page a little
and I did that and I'm Laura Caruso came
in the director for it and we talked a
bit and I between Sebastian and Salvo
his father and Laura being from New York
Italian American there was a lot of
support there
um on both sides as far as knowing the
world knowing what it is and uh wherever
we go we know it's rooted in in a strong
Foundation
I love that I love that so much well
listen the way Salvo expresses his love
is a lot different from the way that
Ellie's family expresses their love I
gotta know what's your love language
Robert like how do you show your love
well I believe in being loving with the
my kids uh and sometimes you have to be
um
uh Stern about stuff I mean there's no
way around it with kids I don't like to
have to do I don't like to have to lay
down the law and stuff like that but
some you just have no choice so on any
parent I think you'd say the same thing
um you always wanted
do the right thing but by the children
and be
um give them the benefit of the doubt
but sometimes it you can't
it's so true listen it's so true I have
a 14 month old part of me oh gosh I'm
like aging she's actually 16 months so I
get the stern you know gotta lay it down
but you love them it's in a loving way
of course
so listen I know you have six kids
um but like have you just had a bit oh
my goodness congratulations I'm so sorry
okay seven
um I gotta know have you always been the
cool dad or have you ever had like the
embarrassing dad moments
I don't think that I'm a cool father I
think
um you know I Sebastian said that about
Salvo that's great
um
I I'm okay you know my kids uh disagree
with me at times and that they're
respectful my daughter my is in 11 she's
gives me a grief sometimes and I argue
with her I adore her but um
you know and my youngest now that'll be
more to come but yeah no that's that's
what it is absolutely absolutely well
listen Robert you have a milestone
birthday this year 80 I believe and
you've been acting for almost 60 years
which is absolutely incredible we're so
you know grateful to see you on our
screens do you ever have anything that
you still want to do in your career or
any like what what would you still like
to accomplish
I I don't know I probably would want to
direct write and direct a movie One More
film but I don't know if I have if I
will but we'll see it I just because
it's a lot of work yeah it's a lot of
work going through a lot of stages it's
uh it's a few years of a commitment and
um but you know I think of it from time
to time
amazing well I hope to see it and um I'm
excited for the world to laugh with you
during this movie so thank you so much
it was wonderful to meet you thank you